Si os digo que Rusia está tirando la casa
por la ventana para financiar la guerra en
Ucrania, seguro, seguro, que a ninguno de
vosotros os va a sorprender.
Todos sabéis que en septiembre de 2022 Rusia
comenzó a movilizar a 300.000 personas para
la guerra, pero es muy posible que no sepáis
nada de esto:
N1(Rusia ampliará el tamaño de sus fuerzas
armadas a 1,5 millones de soldados, según
el ministro de Defensa.
El Kremlin consideraba anteriormente que el
tamaño de las fuerzas armadas rusas era suficiente,
pero eso cambió tras experimentar una resistencia
inesperada y reveses en Ucrania.
Fox News)
El ministro de defensa ruso, Sergey Shoigu,
ha anunciado esta ampliación pase lo que
pase en Ucrania.
Y ojo porque esto tiene implicaciones enormes.
Hablamos de un esfuerzo mucho mayor de lo
que puede parecer a primera vista.
Pensadlo bien…
Desde que las tropas rusas pusieron un pie
en Ucrania en 2022, más de 700 mil personas,
la mayoría de ellos jóvenes, han abandonado
el país.
Por ejemplo, para evitar ser llamados a filas
y terminar metidos en una trinchera bajo tierra
en el Donbass.
Pues bien, juntad ahora esta fuga, con las
bajas sufridas en la guerra y el grave problema
demográfico que sufre Rusia y, entonces os
daréis cuenta del gigantesco reto que supone
destinar otros 500 mil hombres más a las
fuerzas armadas…
Hablamos de medio millón de jóvenes que
no estarán disponibles para estudiar o trabajar
y a los que además habrá que equipar, mantener
y pagar un salario.
Entre unas cosas y otras hablamos de que el
mercado de trabajo ruso puede perder más
de 1,3 millones de jóvenes, en un país que
tiene pocos jóvenes.
Hablamos de casi el 10% de todos los rusos
que tienen entre 19 y 29 años.
C1(“Según los pronósticos que hicimos
antes de la pandemia, para el año 2030 el
número de trabajadores con entre 20 y 40
años se reducirá aproximadamente una cuarta
parte respecto al año 2020.
Esto en sí mismo supondrá un cambio tectónico
y tendrá un gran impacto para la economía.
A esto ahora se suma las pérdidas que estamos
presenciando hoy, [la fuga de profesionales
y los jóvenes movilizados para la guerra].
Doctor Vladimir Gimpelson, Director del Centro
de Estudios del Mercado Laboral de la Escuela
Superior de Economía de Moscú)
Pero eso no es todo.
Fijaos en este gráfico:
Como podéis ver en pantalla Rusia ha empezado
a invertir fuertemente en defensa.
Es lógico, está en guerra.
Si os fijáis, entre 2021 y 2022 su gasto
militar se incrementó un 50%.
Y ¡ojo!
Porque no venían de gastar precisamente poco
en defensa.
Si el compromiso de la OTAN es del 2% del
PIB destinado a gasto militar - y hasta ahora,
pocos países lo cumplían - Rusia casi nunca
ha bajado del 3%.
Además en Ucrania Rusia ha pérdido muchísimo
equipo militar: hablamos de más de 2.300
tanques, miles de vehículos blindados, cientos
de sistemas de artillería, 12 buques de guerra,
casi 140 aviones y helicópteros de combate
y, por supuesto, miles y miles de toneladas
de misiles y munición de todo tipo.
¿Y qué significa esto?
Pues que si quieren reponer todo ese arsenal
van a tener que gastar muchísimos rublos
durante los próximos años.
Y eso sin contar el propio esfuerzo de una
guerra…
Que continúa.
Y, claro, si esto ya de por sí sería un
enorme reto en cualquier circunstancia, con
una economía que no crece y que, además,
está siendo castigada por las sanciones lo
es aún más.
Sí, hasta ahora, la economía rusa, más
o menos ha resistido las sanciones…
Pero las cosas a futuro se ven menos halagüeñas.
Os hemos hablado de ello recientemente aquí
en VisualPolitik.
Y no digamos ya si finalmente se aprueban
las temidas sanciones secundarias, un tipo
de sanción, que no castiga a Rusia sino a
los países y a las empresas que comercien
con Rusia.
Eso podría ponérselo mucho más difícil
a Rusia para puentear las sanciones.
Incluso podría ser un jaque mate.
Ahora bien…
¿Os habéis dado cuenta de una cosa?
Hablamos de mucho más gasto militar y al
mismo tiempo menos trabajadores y menos dinero.
Los que tengáis el colmillo un poco retorcido
quizás estéis pensando que Rusia se puede
terminar convirtiendo en una especie de Corte
del Norte.
Esto es, un país dónde la mayor parte de
los recursos se destinan a las fuerzas armadas…
[Y también, por supuesto, al bolsillo de
Kim, claro está.]
En Corea del Norte, todo, absolutamente todo
gira en torno al ejército y la defensa nacional.
Rusia todavía está mu y lejos de ese escenario,
pero….
¿De dónde va a sacar todo el dinero que
necesita para mantener el esfuerzo bélico?
¿Qué puede suponer todo esto para la economía
rusa?
Pues bien, ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T1(CUESTIÓN DE PRIORIDADES)
¿Cómo es posible que un país que tiene
un PIB similar al de Italia, Canadá o Brasil
sea considerada toda una potencia militar?
(O al menos lo era)
¿Recordáis haber visto vídeo del ejército
brasileño o del ejército canadiense en plan
vamos a comernos el mundo?
Seguro que no.
Pero claro, en Rusia el peso de las fuerzas
armadas es gigantesco.
De hecho, la mayor prioridad de Putin a lo
largo de sus más de 20 años en el poder
ha sido precisamente eso: renovar y fortalecer
las fuerzas armadas.
Para lograrlo dejaron de lado muchas otras
cosas.
Por ejemplo, el 20% de los rusos ni siquiera
tienen agua corriente en casa.
Esto se da, sobre todo, en las regiones más
frías
¿Por qué?
Porque apenas hay infraestructura.
Por ejemplo, una cosa sorprendente de
Rusia es que apenas tienen puentes.
Mientras en Estados Unidos hay alrededor de
600.000 puentes, Rusia, que es 1,7 veces más
grande sólo tiene entre 40 o
70.000 puentes.
Vamos, que Rusia siempre ha gastado mucho
en defensa...
porque
no gastaba en otras partes.
Esto también ocurría en la época soviética
o los
años de Yeltsin.
Y, por supuesto, con Putin en el Kremlin,
el gasto militar es
simplemente intocable.
Atentos.
Cómo podéis ver, a partir del año 2012
Vladimir Putin comenzó a incrementar el esfuerzo
militar de Rusia, y lo hará aún más durante
los próximos años, cuando seguramente el
gasto militar se situará muy por encima del
5% del PIB.
Y no solo eso.
Además de gastar mucho más en el ejército,
el gobierno de Putin también sacó adelante
su famoso plan “Fortaleza Rusia”, una
estrategia que buscaba prepararse para la
guerra y sobre todo, para llegado el caso,
poder soportar las sanciones internacionales.
Por ejemplo, redujeron la deuda externa, aumentaron
las reservas de divisas y trataron de reforzar
sus lazos con Asia y Oriente Medio.
Digamos que durante años el objetivo primordial
no fue hacer crecer la economía sino, sobre
todo, preparar al país para la guerra.
Y eso es en cierto modo lo que les ha permitido
aguantar “tan bien” el castigo de occidente
durante el último año.
Claro que la pregunta qué podemos hacernos
es, todo esto está muy bien, pero, ¿toda
esa previsión será suficiente para mantener
el esfuerzo de guerra?
Es decir, ¿Qué está haciendo Rusia para
evitar una crisis económica fuerte y seguir
financiando la guerra?
Pues básicamente está haciendo 3 cosas para
eludir las sanciones:
Primero, está tratando de incrementar todo
lo que puede sus ventas de petróleo y gas
a países como China o la India para intentar
compensar la pérdida de sus clientes en Europa.
En 2022 las cosas le fueron relativamente
bien, gracias a los mayores precios del petróleo
y el gas, Rusia consiguió ingresar casi un
20%.
Pero 2023 y los próximos años pueden ser
diferentes si no consigue vender mucho, muchísimo
más en Asia.
Este sería su primer gran objetivo, claro
que, no resulta tan sencillo.
Entre otras cosas porque los chinos, a diferencia
de los alemanes y casi todos los demás países
europeos si se toman en serio la seguridad
energética, es decir, no depender demasiado
de un gran proveedor.
Por eso, lo segundo que está haciendo Rusia…
O mejor dicho, el Kremlin, es colocar en estos
mercados a intermediarios con fuertes conexiones
con el gobierno ruso, que compran el petróleo
de este país con descuento y luego lo revenden
en el mercado y a otros países a precios
de mercado.
Todo a cambio de una jugosa comisión para
el Kremlin.
Dicho de otra forma ¿Que occidente pone un
tope al precio del barril de 60 dólares?
¡No hay problema!
Pongo una empresa rusa en la India que es
la que compra el barril a 60 dólares… y
luego lo vende al distribuidor indio y al
mercado internacional solo ligeramente por
debajo del precio de mercado.
La diferencia se la queda Rusia.
De esta forma, podemos saltarnos el tope al
precio del gas.
(Y finalmente, la tercera estrategia: importar
de terceros países ¿Que no puedo comprar
tecnología occidental?
¡No hay problema!
Países como Kazajistán o Kirguistan, que
no están sancionados, importan lo que haga
falta y luego se lo revenden a Rusia.
Eso explica que, de repente, las importaciones
en Armenia se hayan disparado en 2022.
Por supuesto, el proceso es más caro, las
cantidades son limitadas y lo que se consigue
por lo general no es la última tecnología,
pero al menos sirve para cubrir agujeros.
Por ejemplo, para seguir fabricando armas.)
[Claro que esta estrategia se podría ver
truncada si, finalmente, se imponen sanciones
secundarias, aunque esto es tema para otro
vídeo].
Ahora bien, en cierto modo todo esto explica
cómo Rusia ha podido sortear las sanciones
mejor de lo esperado.
Pero el Kremlin necesita más.
No basta con aguantar el golpe sino también
rearmar a su ejército y ampliarlo.
Y la primera pregunta es ¿Es esto suficiente
para lograr la victoria?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2(LAS SOMBRAS RUSAS)
Todos lo sabemos - incluso quienes no quieren
reconocerlo - la guerra en Ucrania le está
yendo francamente mal, muy mal al ejército
ruso.
Sin ir más lejos, aquí en VisualPolitik,
ya os hemos contado cuáles son las principales
razones por las que está fracasando el ejército
ruso.
Y desde luego, noticias como esta nos dejan
muy claro cómo están realmente las cosas:
N2("El ejército no tiene nada": los nuevos
reclutas rusos lamentan la falta de suministros
Los familiares compran equipos y ropa para
los soldados en primera línea debido a los
robos, la corrupción y la mala logística.
The Guardian)
Y aún más.
Los nuevos soldados y reclutas, no sólo carecen
de equipamiento suficiente, tampoco han recibido
prácticamente entrenamiento.
Y cuándo están en el frente es habitual
que muchas veces la comida se retrase o llegue
caducada.
O que, por ejemplo, no existan planes sobre
dónde refugiarse.
Y ni siquiera se trata solo de que estos soldados
apenas reciban equipos, entrenamiento y suministros,
muchas veces también sufren malos tratos.
Sí, en este canal ya os hemos hablado, por
ejemplo, de la “dedovschina”, las crueles
novatadas a los nuevos soldados que los llevan
al límite mental y físico.
Pero es que hay más: los altos rangos militares
también se niegan a informar a las familias
de los soldados sobre su situación.
Y esto aunque parezca mentira es habitual
en el ejército ruso.
Pasó en Afganistán y volvió a pasar en
Chechenia, donde hubo el caso de madres que
fueron a buscar a sus hijos a las zonas de
combate.
Es decir, es decir es habitual que las estructuras
militares en Rusia traten a los soldados básicamente
como carne de cañón.
¿El resultado?
La moral por los suelos.
Falta de equipos, falta de preparación, falta
de suministros, problemas con la cadena de
mando…
Es la receta perfecta para el fracaso, que
es exactamente lo que explica lo ocurrido.
La pregunta es, ¿Y qué se puede hacer?
¿En qué están pensando exactamente en Moscú?
Pues, básicamente en tirar de talonario.
Ya hemos visto cómo han disparado su gasto
militar.
(Ahora lo que Putin le ha pedido a su gobierno
es que alimenten la industria militar con
nuevos contratos y pedidos.
¿El problema?
El problema es que la corrupción, el desfase
tecnológico, las sanciones y la baja productividad
hacen que esto sea una misión particularmente
difícil.
Incluso aunque puedan comprar ciertos suministros
en países como Armenia.
Para colmo, el gobierno ruso redujo en 2020
sus pedidos militares…
Lo que ha hecho que muchas líneas de producción
estén hoy cerradas.
Por ejemplo, mientras que entre 2011 y 2020
el país estuvo produciendo entre 8 y 12 bombarderos
Su-34 anualmente, el contrato de 2021 a 2024
prevé la fabricación de solo 5 al año.)
Lo mismo pasa con algunos misiles guiados
como los de la clase Tornado.
En este caso, tenemos datos de los modelos
9M544 y 9M549.
Hablamos de misiles guiados con un rango de
unos 150 km.
Pues bien, en 2017 se produjeron entre 220
y 230 unidades.
Un año después, en 2018, la producción
bajó a unos 150.
En principio no hay evidencias de que la fábrica
pueda aumentar la producción ¿Por qué?
Principalmente por falta de mano de obra.
Se estima que la industria
rusa necesita 400.000 nuevos trabajadores.
Y como os podéis imaginar, entre los rusos
que han abandonado el país y los que se van
a la guerra, la mano de obra escasea.
Pensad que, para fabricar armas modernas se
necesitan profesionales cualificados.
Rusia no sólo está perdiendo a sus mejores
profesionales.
Además, tiene problemas para atraer a trabajadores
cualificados del extranjero ¿Conclusión?
Este gasto militar irá, principalmente, a
fabricar armas menos avanzadas: artillería,
tanques de herencia soviética, etc…
Y la pregunta es ¿Qué está pasando en el
resto de la economía rusa?
T3(¿BIG MAC…
MADE IN RUSSIA?))
Por si alguno se lo estaba preguntando: no,
Rusia no está entrando en una economía de
guerra.
Quedaría muy bien un titular clickbait comparando
a Rusia con Corea del Norte pero las magnitudes
no son comparables.
Por ejemplo, según las estimaciones de Estados
Unidos, en el año 2021, Corea del Norte llegó
a destinar un 26% de su PIB en defensa.
En el caso de Rusia, en el peor de los casos
podríamos hablar de un 6%.
Pensad que Rusia tiene una economía mucho
más diversificada.
(Además, el mejor argumento de Putin es que
las sanciones internacionales están afectando
poco a los rusos, pero claro, si de repente
decretara una economía de guerra y obligara
a muchas empresas a trabajar exclusivamente
para el ejército ese panorama podría cambiar
por completo:
Los mercados empezarían a quedarse desabastecidos,
la inflación seguramente se iría por las
nubes y si la guerra no terminara pronto las
consecuencias podrían ser catastróficas.
Este es uno de los grandes problemas que tiene
el ejército ruso: necesita equipos, mano
de obra y todo tipo de suministros.
Pero al mismo tiempo el Kremlin necesita tener
apaciguados a los rusos.)
Y diréis ¿Qué ha pasado entonces con todas
las empresas occidentales que se han ido del
país?
Pues cosas como esta.
N3(Los restaurantes McDonald's de Rusia reabren
bajo una nueva marca
Con el nombre de Vkusno & tochka ("Sabroso
y ya está"), la cadena de comida rápida
parece una copia del original estadounidense.
The Guardian)
Exacto, queridos amigos de VisualPolitk, Rusia
ha vuelto a ofrecer comida rápida a sus ciudadanos,
aunque esta vez sin el Big Mac en el menú.
Básicamente, un oligarca ruso, Alexander
Govor, ha comprado todos los restaurantes
de McDonalds en Rusia.
Este hombre tenía ya la franquicia de McDonalds
en varias regiones.
Ahora se ha quedado con el negocio de toda
Rusia y hasta ha dicho que abrirá nuevos
restaurantes.
Por ahora, ha mantenido toda la plantilla
de más de 60.000 trabajadores.
Por cierto, como nota curiosa: en el acuerdo
McDonald´s se reserva el derecho de recomprar
toda la franquicia en los próximos 15 años.
Es decir, que muchas empresas occidentales
todavía esperan volver a Rusia algún día.
Pero esto es tema para otro vídeos…
¿Y qué pasa con otros sectores más tecnológicos?
Pues, por ejemplo, al marcharse todas los
grandes fabricantes como Renault, ha llegado
el momento de oro para las marcas locales.
Atentos a esta noticia.
N4(El fabricante ruso de coches de la era
soviética regresará a Rusia con la ayuda
de China, según un informe.
Dos décadas después de su quiebra, la empresa
automovilística de la era soviética Moskvich
planea un renacimiento en Rusia, al parecer
asociándose con el fabricante chino JAC para
producir vehículos en medio del éxodo de
las principales marcas.
Drive)
Por su parte Lada va a volver a producir su
mítico Granta Classic del 2011.
Eso sí, con tecnología de los 90 y sin airbags,
ABS ni cinturones de seguridad.
Dicho de otra forma: hablamos de productos
de peor calidad… pero hechos en Rusia.
(El caso es que ejemplos como el de Lada o
la nueva cadena de hamburguesas rusas son
el claro ejemplo de que Rusia está reconvirtiendo
toda su economía.
Por supuesto estas empresas serán mucho menos
productivas, fabricaran cosas obsoletas y
difícilmente serán una alternativa…
Pero esta estrategia de nacionalizar la economía
con empresas rusas puede ayudar a evitar el
desastre.
A corto plazo, incluso, este cambio y el mayor
gasto militar del gobierno pueden hacer que
el PIB se mantenga.
Eso es en buena medida lo que explica porque
algunas organizaciones como el FMI apuntan
a que la economía rusa puede incluso crecer
un 0,3% en 2023.
Sin embargo, esto tiene trampa.
Producir misiles puede contribuir a mejorar
las cifras de un año, pero una vez que se
utilizan se pierden y lo que queda es la enorme
factura que ha tenido que pagar el gobierno.
Y algo parecido ocurre con la producción
de Ladas de mucha peor calidad.)
Y, por otro lado, tenemos un problema de escasez
de mano de obra.
Aquí es donde está el gran problema de Rusia
en estos momentos.
Y no es un problema pequeño porque, sin talento,
es imposible levantar una economía.
Y, ahora mismo, Putin está pidiendo demasiado
a su tejido productivo.
Pero por ahora la pregunta es para ti: ¿De
verdad puede Rusia llegar a reemplazar todo
el arsenal que está perdiendo?
¿Hasta qué punto podrá fabricar munición
de precisión en las cantidades que necesitan?
¿Veremos como Rusia decreta una economía
de guerra?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no
olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribiros a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos
en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.